last week we discovered that for the
first time ever London's murder rate
overtook New York's more than 50 people
have been slain in the capital this year
and scores murdered nationwide the
government has announced new legislation
to help fight violent crime which
actually won't do a damn thing to stop
young black people being murdered by
other black people rising knife crime
does involve race and it's not racist to
say that because it is young black men
being stabbed and not as former race
equality boss Trevor Phillips points out
young white boys in Surrey predominantly
black areas have to be policed
differently too many white areas without
people screaming racism because
communities are different and they need
different ways to control crime yes we
need more officers visible on our
streets but Teresa Mays decision to
reduce stop and search by nearly 80% has
had disastrous consequences we mustn't
listen to the liberal elites screaming
that it's racist - bringing and bringing
it back will damage relations with black
communities
what's racist is letting black kids die
horrible deaths to prove what a diverse
and compassionate society we are Wow
first of all I am thrilled that you care
about the fact that there are young
black children dying on it why would you
say that I'm saying you've just shown
that you care and I welcome that why did
you have a problem with that girl well
because you're not what I thought I
don't care that was the thing I thought
we were not debating because you
established it in your intro but anyway
the thing I have a problem with is the
approach do you suggest as the answer
right so I'm not that interested in
whether London's murder rates higher
than New York's if there are people
dying on our streets that is a problem
doesn't matter where you compare it to
the fact is that there is something
going wrong and that these are complex
things and that I absolutely think that
we need to make it a political and
social priority to address it to reduce
this to a question of stop and search is
in my view completely misguided because
stop and search has not proved itself an
effective
tarrant against violent crime and just
to put into perspective you mentioned
the fact that stop and search has been
reduced by the police the reduction in
spoken search has affected white people
far more than it has black people black
people are still being stopped and
searched almost at the same level they
were before the cuts so the idea that
this is the reason for the rise in
violent crime is because black people
not being stopped since actually well
don't just see the fix for all of the
stuff insert reduce and this is look at
this graphic stop and search figures in
in 2011 there were and 2010 11 1.2
million in 2060 and 17 it's three
hundred thousand that is not just all
white people are not being stopped in
well the the number of stops and search
on white people has been reduced by
nearly thirty percent and the number of
stopping searches on black people is
reduced by just 10 percent and there are
also facts that show that stop and
search on black people it's far less
likely to lead to any evidence of crime
now the picture that's being painted
here is that this is just not simply not
true in the past four years knife crime
has escalated by nearly 70 percent in
the past years researchers are not
leading to review the prevention of that
crime can I come in and that's the fact
III really do believe in speaking
frankly and bluntly if there's a if
there's a disproportionate number of
Muslims for example involved in
terrorism that I I would like to be able
to acknowledge that likewise if there
are and there are a disproportionate
number of young black kids involved in
knife crime we have to acknowledge that
yeah I do believe however that the
correlation in rising crime with the
reduction in stop and search needs to be
tested scientifically and so when the
College of policing and the Home Office
both ran independently surveys on the
effectiveness of stop and searching
reduction of crime they found that there
was no significant relationship and the
word significant was used in the
increase of stop and search and the
decrease of violent crime in the area if
on the other hand the science
demonstrated that the two who were
related in a causal way rather than a
correlative way III would have a
difficult harder time making the police
now don't have the government backing to
take the weapons off kids what I make is
that crime has been falling
overall in New York as well as church no
no yes my second point that stop and
search has also been terminated in New
York and crime has been incredibly
successful in the middle of you too so I
could be the victim of a crime if I'm
not there for drive-by shooting can I
just clarify with you after you said
something really interesting you said
the number or you had figures that show
the number of stops on black people has
reduced where did those figures come
from those figures come from I think
there was home office data I mean I
would use by nearly 30% and the stops on
people are black and not just black but
black and I know you want any reduce ok
ok because those fingers didn't seem to
char me down the Carol's [ __ ] the
general thing is not breaking down the
decrease you're both right you're both
right stop and search itself stop and
search should be brought back Theresa
May was criminally irresponsible when
she mentioned the police in the way that
she did because and it is
disproportionate that it is young
necessary black non-white I think we say
if you look at the gallery of photos of
the victims in London they're not all
necessarily black summer mixed-race
what's my name
you are right as well it is not solely
going to be solved by bringing back stop
and search there are massive issues
there are issues of absent fathers many
of these particular lads grow up without
dads being right there excuse me there
are family issues as well there's areas
deprived of Education which is a huge
school exclusion in so it is a multi
fact and I hate to use this expression
but multifaceted it is not as simple to
stop and search great to be allowed to
get it let's just see what Tereza May
said when she was Home Secretary nobody
wins when stop and searches miss applied
it is a waste of police time it is
unfair especially to young black men it
is bad for public confidence in the
police apart from the fact that it shows
you what a few years of Prime Minister
no if you go back to what she was saying
at the time she was saying people the
police were using this indiscriminately
in many cases and if you actually look
at the figures from imagine this
inspector of Constabulary 27% of stop
and searches happened but without
reasonable grounds even though they've
been approved by a scene which means
they're illegally but let's not get deep
into into just a stop and search there I
mean clearly and all the politicians who
you see talking about this who've been
involved talk about this is multifaceted
there's lots of reasons for what's
happening actually you could be very
careful although there's a spike
happening in in deaths this year
actually we're nowhere near where we
were five six seven years ago I mean
they they came down for long time on
them you know you've seen this spike now
I see it's important that we understand
what you can do about it but I think
just to jump on I never sit and nowhere
in that intro did I say that stopping
Sturge that that was gonna solve it I
didn't say that but I think what we have
to acknowledge this is what Trevor
Phillips knows more about this than I do
he says you know we have to acknowledge
that this has a racial and cultural
aspect to it and and what he also said
which I find very interesting he said
all his experience of black families is
that they welcome this because it's
they're young people who are being slave
so they're not worried about it in the
same way that lots of other people seem
to be I'm worried about is us framing
this debate in a way that actually
doesn't get to the solutions
no one wants black children dying on our
streets who would want that that's why I
start out by saying I welcome your
commitment that if we're serious about
helping young black people who are
getting caught up in this crime
why have we flashed youth services that
are proven to give young people
alternatives to the violence on the
streets look at the Scottish model where
they've taken a public health approach
to stabbings and they have the 35
stabbings of young people happen last
year none were in Scotland
Stafford scholars community I taste from
Tottenham let's hear what he has to say
do you really and the policy makers
really think that the kids are sitting
at home this morning watching this
program to learn that there's fewer
police and then thinking as a result of
that we're gonna go out there and do
something it doesn't matter the numbers
of the police it's about the pressure
that the state the oppressive state is
putting on these young people that's
making them respond in the way that they
are now whether we agree with the
precise language or not yeah whether we
agree with the precise language I think
the broader point is trying to make
there is to our first point that there
is a whole bunch of services for young
people that have been cut they're not
feeling like they're being heard the
opportunities they're lacking and I
worry that actually perhaps though yes
we need to have a toolkit you respond to
an array of responses I'm not so sure
it's scientifically stop and search
hasn't been demonstrated because I don't
know whether you all saw some chilling
work done by Sky News is peerless Martin
run when he actually interviewed a gang
member
about the third thief of the right I
don't know you so if he didn't have lead
some of the viewers now oh this is
Martin Braun from Sky News talking to a
gang member you have to listen carefully
for some of the audio a gang member who
identified himself solely as Dylan you
have to do what I did but I said that I
need the money in their turn and I see
this guy walking past me in an S Rolex
so I had to stab him to get that loosen
up so I had to stab you six times that
sounds like you nearly killed him no I
think I don't know shocking you know I
just want to say sir I get I get the
problems that a lot of young black black
use are facing but you know we can't say
that's the same for everybody you know
when kids come out on the streets with
ten inch blades and machetes and they
kill people and then they boast about it
on social media they're not vulnerable
kids that we're you know we have to
accept that some of what's happening is
is actually wicked it's it's not all to
do with vulnerable kids some people and
the way this boy is talking okay